mon entreprise s'appelle les volailles
d'huguette g ouvrir cette petite
entreprise parce que je propose du
produit pays et c'est que 100% volaille
et ça j'ai ouvert ma petite entreprise
de 10 octobre 2014
on élève notre rôle à nous mêmes on
on tue on france fort et on vend
directement dans notre petite
charcuterie votre projet à nous c'était
de proposer aux clients du pot du pays
de l'élevage à l'assiette
avant je travaillais dans une grande
surface pendant 14 ans et ensuite je me
suis retrouvé au chômage et comme je
lève de la volaille des oies des canards
des poules et
j'ai dit bon ben je vais créer une
petite entreprise comme ça je serai pas
au chômage et c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
tél
j'aime artisans comprise et je suis fier
de travailler droit
vous conseiller à la chambre des métiers
qui m'a aidé à monter mon dossier de
projet et j'ai présenté mon dossier au
comité de l'initiative et entreprendre
et j'ai eu un avis favorable et j'ai eu
mon prêt d'honneur 24 mai 7 50 euros
pour mon activité
mon entourage m'a beaucoup aidé surtout
premièrement par un bon mari parce que
c'était vraiment dur pour lui parce que
par moment j'étais énervé
étaient fatigués mais ils étaient là il
m'a soutenu
le salon reste un symbole fort elle au
niveau psychologique au niveau d'avant
sorte au quiz parce qu'elle voit loin
elle c'est une forme maintenant je
commence à déclencher tout d'un coup
elle va très loin elle veut elle veut
que son entreprise
elle m'a dit elle veut que sa propre
argent lille et elle ce qu'elle m'a dit
m'a vraiment touchée elle mais elle m'a
dit qu'elle passait sur maintenant à
l'économie de vivre
ce que le client s'y voit ces deux
produits de qualité c'est un pro du pays
et en plus ils voient qu'il ya la
transformation avec la volaille c'est à
dire entre j'ai fait la saucisse la
galantine des ruines de là
il est
pour le développement pour les années à
venir je vois mon entreprise beaucoup
évolué c'est à dire
voir le projet de découvrir plein de
gaieté dans toutes les
les villes des
c'est la réunion est aussi exporter nos
produits en métropole parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des clients qui
achètent des produits chez moi qui
envoie pour leur famille en métropole et
la familia demande quand vous allez
acheter la saucisse aller chez mamie
guest parce que j'aime la vie guette les
saucissons beau